[applause]
first of all, I would like us to
thank those who are with us now,
if possible, with a moment of silence to
honor the memory of all the fallen heroes,
I am asking for a
big thank you for your strength, for your
motivation, for the fact that we understand that things
happen differently at the front, well Exactly  here
are the people on whose shoulders our
state remains, the issue is not in Donbas, that's why I want
to tell you here in Donbas, you protect the
whole of Ukraine,
because after Donbas, they will do all this
in other
towns in other towns of our
state, because they don't want anything
Ukrainian. I'm sure  in this 100%.  and
therefore, on your shoulders is the protection of not Donbas, the
protection of all of Ukraine
for the past 7 days,
yesterday was a
non-official corps where
people suffered, a
patient died, one patient died,
another patient is in serious
condition